the first humanitarian Convoy arrived in
the karabakh region with 70 tons of
essential supplies
the Latin Corridor between Azerbaijan
and Armenia has been open to allowing
Aid and a safe passage for those who
want to exit the azerbaijani territory
maku says it is also sending Fuel and
supplies after a ceasefire agreement
with ethnic Armenian leaders
hundreds remain stranded and ethnic
Armenians seek Russian peacekeepers
protection who now controlled this
Airport
most people fled fearing the arrival of
azerbaijani soldiers despite Baku saying
that people of Armenian descent will
have constitutional rights but many
including Valerie think it's safer to
move on
who can give us the guarantee we found a
liter of gasoline ran away and came here
shall we go so that the young people are
killed along the way
Armenian prime minister nicolean is
seeking effective mechanisms of
protection for Armenians it
continue to face the threat of ethnic
cleansing in recent days humanitarian
Aid has arrived but this does not change
the situation and unless real living
conditions are created an effective
mechanisms of protection from ethnic
cleansing then the Armenians of nagorna
Karbach will see Exile from their
homelands Armenians as their ancestral
Homeland but the mountainous region is
internationally recognized as part of
Azerbaijan
the latest military push which
Azerbaijan calls a counter-terrorism
offensive was aimed at disbanding and
disarming ethnic Armenian Fighters
who've now surrendered their weapons
this is a
European that below used to belong to
the Armenian armed forces detachments
and also irregular Armenian Armenian
forces that were here
it was seized from them just in the last
two days during the last two days
amid mounting International concern
about Armenian civilians Azerbaijan is
assuring karabakh residents that there
will be no prosecution tens of thousands
of ethnic Armenians have lived in the
karabakh region for over three decades
now that the azerbaijani government
tells them that civilians and those who
lay down their weapons will not be
prosecuted will take time for people to
decide whether they want to stay or
leave
karabakh region
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera